doesn't Trump says he hopes there will
be no meddling or tampering during next
week's election he says his
administration has spent a lot of time
and money to try to prevent that tonight
we go inside the government's plans to
try to keep the election election secure
here's chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge where the Fox News
exclusive we haven't seen any activity
that we can attribute directly to a
foreign nation homeland security
secretary Kirsten nielsen will oversee
the nationwide Situation Room on
election night the tracks cyber threats
to voter databases as well as online
efforts using propaganda and
disinformation to influence voters
perceptions and decision-making we're
gonna have the most secure election in
the modern age Nielson spoke exclusively
with bunks about the new security
measures a day after she FBI director
Christopher ray and the nation's
intelligence chief DNI Dan Coates
briefed the president his basic message
was elections are the heart of our
democracy it's extraordinarily important
that Americans have confidence in them
the National Cyber Security command
center and DHS have added monitoring
that covers about 90 percent of
registered voters known as Albert
censors the program flank cyber
intruders now DHS says more than half of
all states have completed vulnerability
assessments if there was an attack on
the voting Tuesday
there would be a u.s. government
response that's the president's position
yes absolutely there's a lot of
reporting it would be a cyber response
is that on the table everything is on
the table the intelligence community
recently warned Russia China and Iran
leverage social media to amplify issues
that divide voters last cycle a Russian
troll factory masqueraded online as US
citizens earlier this year
Beijing sponsored pro-china ads to sway
American farmers we continue to see
extraordinarily aggressive actions by
multiple countries to influence the way
in which Americans think and in some
cases such as China to perhaps change
our policies Nielsen notes foreign
governments and hackers may not breach
voting systems but she warns they still
exploit election night to sow confusion
discord and mistrust by placing stories
in social media or state-sponsored media
that something was wrong on election day
Homeland Security says they will also
partner with the RNC and DNC secretary
Nielsen said Americans should not jump
to conclusions if there is a problem and
wait for an independent assessment from
FBI DHS and the intelligence community
Brett captain Harwich live in New York
Catherine thank you